one of the challenges associated with
this thinker of massive importance Georg
Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel is figuring out
where to start and not just in general
like where to start with his works but
where to start in talking about how to
productively study him and unfortunately
for these videos about self-directed
study they already have a kind of
structure and format and so I'm going to
honor that although I'm going to deviate
from it a bit as we discuss this
particular thinker and how you might get
something out of his work so I typically
begin these by talking about why would
you want to study the Thinker who were
looking at at all why why approach them
what's important about them what are you
going to get out of studying them what
could be your motivation and I think
when it comes to Hegel there's there's
just a vast variety of things that we
could bring up so you know we could
start by talking about his importance as
a philosopher to begin with you know
he's he's up there with Plato and
Aristotle and Descartes and you know
going back a little bit Thomas Aquinas
or Augustine at least in the history of
Western philosophy love him hate him
don't read him read him it's at least
acknowledged by many people that
historically he has been of massive
importance and influence and
some people do consider him to be you
know not just somebody who was
historically influential but a
first-rate philosopher that's that's a
big open question that we can ask so he
is massively influential I think if
you're going to study
philosophy and you're going to try to do
some justice to you know what we
traditionally have called it's Canon or
its history you probably want to read at
least some of Hegel to to get an idea of
what is going on in his text what he
brings to the table what he has to offer
and you could get this through a lot of
different Works some of them by Hagel
himself some of them secondary
literature or even appropriations of
Hegel we'll talk about the difference
and the difficulty of sometimes
distinguishing between the two of those
a little bit later on and this you could
also perhaps read Hegel out of a kind of
historical interest he has been
massively influential in history itself
so it's not just that he was somebody
along the way who had some great ideas
that other people rejected interpreted
played off of appropriated
he's also you know in the middle of
history and looking back at history and
looking ahead and even speculating about
the very meaning of History itself so
that you know in the late 20th century
we could have people taking up a
particular interpretation of Hegel in
the end of History you may recognize
Francis fukuyama and his kojevian
interpretation so that's another reason
historical interest
um I I think that there's also you know
like with many of the thinkers that we
would want to study you can read them
for the positive doctrines the
contributions that they're making you
could say I want to know what Hegel
actually thinks about this matter about
say human Freedom or about how Society
ought to be organized or about the you
know the nature of space and time or
pick any other sort of topic and you
could say well I want to know what the
guy actually has to say about these
matters and you know first I mean to
figure out what he has to say and then
I'll figure out is he actually correct
about these things if he is correct
maybe I'll take on some of his ideas and
incorporate them into my life and I
think that that actually can be very
productive approach to looking at not
just Hegel but other authors as well you
don't have to go in a hundred percent
and say well I'm going to believe
everything that the person says I'm
going to mine them for things that I
think could be insightful or useful and
and you know so maybe Hegel is right
about certain things that you would want
to take on you've got to study him in
order to figure that out I would also
say that although there isn't a single
clearly laid out dialectical method in
hegel's work and anybody who tells you
that there is just one single thing is
selling you a line or misinformed
themselves as we'll talk about in a bit
particularly with respect to thesis
antithesis synthesis the so-called
hegelian dialectic which is not not so
um you can actually buy working through
his texts learn a good bit about how to
think dialectically how by following it
out sort of like tracing out other
people's work as an artist you learn how
to to draw yourself or looking at models
you know this is how I could paint so
there's there's something of that in
studying hegel's works as well
I I think that there's also kind of this
is going to sound a little facetious but
it's along the lines of Well everybody's
doing it so why shouldn't I now not
everybody's reading Hegel there's a lot
of people who claim to be reading or
studying Hegel who let's be honest
actually aren't they're just you know
doing a little bit of stuff and they're
not really spending a lot of time with
this text but there are a lot of people
out there and and not just in the
present but tracing all the way back to
hegel's own time
who thought that this was really quite
valuable and you know you could say well
that many people smart people probably
aren't you know entirely wrong now to be
sure there's many smart people who've
also dismissed Hegel or criticized him
sometimes fairly sometimes unfairly and
maybe you should take them into account
as well but I think there's something
there and then you know finally if you
are kind of a joiner type and you want
to be on as we call it team Hegel I've
done a other video about what I call
text with auras hegel's phenomenology of
spirit is one of those that I discuss
because there's a lot of people who feel
like Hegel unlocked the mysteries of the
universe and it's usually the
phenomenology that they're turning to
and not his other works that they also
should be reading that they they take as
as doing this and you know so you might
be reading Hegel because you want to be
a hegelian just like some people I
suppose would you know read Descartes or
Hume for similar reasons or they read
stoic literature because they're on team
stoicism or you know Thomas Aquinas and
Aristotle with others and I'm not going
to say that that's a terrible reason I
understand that that's going to be the
motivation for some people but hopefully
these other possible motivations would
be more predominant you know thinking
that hey there's there's something here
that I can get out of this I don't have
to buy into the whole uh totality of his
works but I'm going to get some valuable
insights from it he's clearly an
important thinker who has some
interesting things you could be wrong
about everything but I won't know
until I actually study it for myself so
that that's probably enough at this
point about you know motivation for
studying this great thinker uh guard
Friedrich William Friedrich Hegel
if you're going to be engaging in
self-directed study of any philosopher
there are some natural questions that
will arise about their texts and
additions and you know if they're not
writing in English the translations that
you should be relying upon and we're
going to put off like the order in which
you might approach the text to the next
section and we're going to talk here
about some of the more practical
questions that arise from the very
beginning
and I'll say that you know with Hegel
it's not just a matter of like what
translations we're going to use or look
at or acquire there's some other things
that I think for many readers especially
given the notorious difficulty of
hegel's texts and his style of writing
these are going to arise so you know
one common issue that comes up with some
self-directed study readers people who
are engaging in this is am I smart
enough to actually read this and get
something out of this and that's not
just with Hegel people worry about that
with Aristotle or with David Hume or
pick whoever you want but with Hegel I
think a lot of people a lot more people
probably have that worry and I would say
right off the bat don't let that keep
you from going into hegel's texts
you're not going to get everything out
of the text any more than you do with
anybody else but it's probably going to
be a steeper learning curve at first
with Hegel he's not too hard for readers
it's just that it takes a lot of work
and and some of that is hegel's own
fault he is not a great clear stylist by
any means you know and this goes not
just for in English translation
but also in the original German as well
you know I don't know anybody who reads
Hegel because he's such a wonderful
writer they read it for the ideas that
they're they're trying to get and so you
know that might be something to keep in
mind uh right off the bat
another thing is as you approach
hegelian texts
um perhaps more so than with many other
philosophers you may feel yourself to be
kind of in a foreign world where people
are talking a weird language and you're
not even sure I mean you know what some
of the words mean like and the more less
but then there's all these other
bits of terminology and you know like
you can think of it as an entire lore
that is permeating these texts and and
you know that is going to be part of
what you're going to be struggling with
and eventually hopefully making some
progress into and understanding so that
that's you know some important stuff to
keep in mind now let's let's get to the
the nitty-gritty now you're going to say
well which tax which versions which
editions which translations should I be
reading and I'm going to talk about this
in the next section I don't actually
suggest beginning where almost everybody
seems to want to begin today with the
phenomenology of spirit or in one
earlier translation the phenomenology of
mind but I know that a lot of people are
going to do that anyway so let's talk
you know rather briefly about
translations of the phenomenology of
spirit so we're kind of fortunate in
that in the past these were the two main
ones
um you know an older one uh you know the
phenomenology of mine translated by JB
Bailey uh with you know an introduction
by uh Georg lichtenheim
um and this one has been more or less
surpassed
um it's not gonna hurt you to read it
but I I don't actually suggest beginning
your study of the phenomenology with
this there are some people who really
enjoy this particular older version in
the time that I was
first studying Hegel back in graduate
school this was the sort of standard
text by Miller and each of these texts I
will mention too you know consulted the
previous translations they didn't just
start out you know completely raw one of
the things that you're going to find
which is definitely an improvement of
the one over the other first of all
getting the language a little bit more
right although Miller does tend towards
you know a little bit of
monkeying around with the language is
that the Bailey translation does not
have numbered paragraphs
the Miller translation does and that is
quite important because in the
literature on this and you know
resources that are available you're
going to see people referencing all
right in paragraph 149 enforce in the
understanding here's what's happening
now the numbering is not exactly the
same from addition to addition so we
should mention that as well and then you
know in the the last decade we have had
three new translations in English come
out of the phenomenology we have this
one by uh Cambridge University press
Terry pankard this is actually at this
point in time my favorite translation
um I would suggest you know maybe
getting the uh the Miller and also
getting the Pinker translation but there
are these other two as well Michael
Inwood has a quite good translation as
well that came out from Oxford
University press
so that's that's kind of nice to have
and then there's this other one peter
fuss and John Dobbins the phenomenology
of spirit from University of Notre Dame
press
and for you know for some reasons but
I'll tell you about I'm not as big on
this one I've I've looked at like some
of the
ways in which things are rendered and
the vocabulary that's being used and
this is a lot of subjective preference I
would say
I would say that you know Miller you
just kind of get used to you he's been
around for such a long time it's hard to
get away from it but I think Pinkard is
is really quite good staying very close
to the the German text and letting you
kind of make up your mind I think the
Inwood is is often quite good as well
I'm a little less sold on some of the
word choices in the Foos and Dobbins and
so maybe I I wouldn't go with that and
there's uh some other issues as well the
fuson Dobbins you notice the very first
paragraph is quite short in this well
that's because they've taken the first
paragraph and broken it up into two
paragraphs so their numbering doesn't
actually match the numbering in in these
other
three volumes and I will mention that
you know at a certain point in the uh
Pinker the numbering is changing from
that in the Miller and then coming back
to it those aren't really that big of a
deal and you could get any of these you
get your hands on any of them and you
know you can understand some things I
will also uh point out that
a translation sometimes isn't just a
translation there'll be some other
things you want to take a look at the
introduction
pinkard's introduction you know has got
hegel's path to the phenomenology it's
giving you a lot of importance
background a discussion what is a
phenomenology uh brief overview of the
book and you know at the end there's a
nice index Millers of course uh has all
of these summaries that he's providing
you know a little three to four line uh
discussions of what's happening
inwoods this book is quite thick and
that's because he's not only got you
know an editor's introduction which is
worth reading I would say for its own
sake but also he provides you with his
own commentary a much more extensive one
in the back and he like some of the
others have glossaries of key terms
which is quite nice to have since Hegel
does have all that terminology
in the fuson Dobbins there is also an
introduction here
you know here's and here's actually an
interesting line from it as for our
translation our primary goal is to
render hegel's argument perspicuous
seeing through in a triple sense seeing
Through The Eyes of disparate modes of
self-consciousness seeing the potential
deficiencies delusions and deceptions of
each and seeing through to the whole art
seeing through the whole argument to its
ultimate conclusion right interpreting
it as an argument is already sort of a
choice there and then you know as we get
to the back there is a conceptual and
topical index uh which is kind of nice
with you know telling you what what
sections you're going to find it in
I will also point out that the Foos and
Dobbins not only doesn't have the same
numbering it also from section to
section begins the numbering again which
can be a bit confusing so we've got you
know already here we have these five
different
distinct
translations of the phenomenology of
spirit so you have a wide choice in
English of what it is that you're going
to be studying I wouldn't worry over
much about having the best translation I
would worry more about
the better and the worse so obviously
you don't want to be you know just using
the Bailey translation the Miller
translation is okay it's kind of still
kind of a standard reference but I think
it's being superseded in favor of some
of these others that'll probably
Generations from now uh be considered
more important does that have to weigh
on you right now no no that that's I
mean you don't have to worry about
future posterity as you approach this
for the very first time but it's it's
kind of good to keep in mind and you're
going to find similar issues with uh
hegel's other you know massively
important works for example the science
of logic you can find a lot of old
copies of older translations out there
but you can also find newer translations
and I would I would go with the newer
ones in this because the in some parts
the newer are not only using a
vocabulary that's closer to us in time
but you might say this is over
generalizing there's less sloppiness
about how to render things I I realized
this recently when a tutorial student
wanted to go and look at a particular
section of the science of logic and I
was comparing the two different
translations and I was like this older
translation
they're uh taking a few liberties with
the chapter headings right Dawson they
were translating as determinate being
rather than his existence so you know
there's there's some things like that to
keep in mind but I don't think you have
to be super concerned about
um you know having the best translation
so maybe that'll put your mind at ease
about this next we'll talk about the you
know details which books you should be
checking out how to get the most out of
your foray into Hegel
so as you've heard me mention and you
might have seen me say in other places I
actually don't suggest that if you're
going to study Hegel you begin with the
as so many people want to do the
phenomenology of spirits a cool book
there's a lot of great stuff there but
there are some serious difficulties in
approaching it and one of the biggest of
these is that Hegel typically doesn't
name names he will go through all of
these interesting dialectical advances
and you've got to figure out or find
some commentary to tell you
who and what he's talking about right so
I don't actually suggest beginning with
this and for a number of years I've been
as people ask me giving a kind of Pat
answer saying you know you should begin
with some of his lectures and in
particular uh one of two different sets
of lectures and they actually are kind
of flipped this is what we call a chiasm
there's lectures on the history of
philosophy and then there's lectures on
the philosophy of History sometimes the
philosophy of world history right and so
I think that those are both good places
to begin
and one of the big reasons is you get to
see who he's talking about because he
names names so in the section on you
know stoicism in the phenomenology you
know he's he's telling you some stuff
but he never names any any stoics at all
and his his rendering of stoicism and
the phenomenology is admittedly a little
bit
weak right it's it's focusing on certain
aspects that he's interested in and
ignoring others in the uh discussion of
stoicism in the history of philosophy
there's still some gaps but he's
actually saying here's what crucipus
says here's what uh you know or what we
know about crucipus from other people
saying and here's what uh this thinker
says here's what this thinker says
here's what what here's the ideas that
they're putting forth so that's that's a
bit more helpful same thing with
discussing historical matters in the
phenomenology you often gotta you know
kind of think to yourself okay so what
is actually happening here in terms of
wealth and state power who does he mean
you know in the philosophy of History he
will actually tell you what what he's
got in mind right and so that's that's
kind of good and you're gonna get way
more in the philosophy of History I just
opened this up to sort of a random page
and here he's talking about the
objective work of art right so it's not
just history but also the development of
culture and you know bringing in other
things political institutions art
religion all of that that sort of stuff
you'll also get a good sense of how he
sees things developing and building and
flowing and differentiating them from
each other with those two sets of
lectures
I also thought that you know there might
be some other decent starting points and
one is
um you know I have the German here I
bought this back in graduate school and
I've you know taken a lot of toll on it
the system kite which is also called the
system of ethical life it doesn't really
work and I think this could be a decent
interesting introduction for readers to
you know at least get used to hegelian
terminology and hegel's way of
organizing things you don't necessarily
have to agree with everything that he's
saying in here but there's a coherent
well worked out discussion another work
that could be quite worthwhile is what
is often called the I'm trying to find
it right here the philosophical uh
prophetudic there we go
um and this one is you know propadutic
is like
you know what you you have students
reading so that they can make sense out
of something that's a bit more
complicated and you know these are sort
of uh guides for pot for his students
and you know you notice that uh so we've
got the parts of the propadutic in
relation to the later works which is
quite nice here gives you an idea of how
these things connect to each other and
then it's like short little passages
giving you more or less like the
hegelian take in in of course the
abstract about a number of different
things and he begins with the science of
laws morals and religion for the lower
class the the earlier students right and
then he's got logic
um you know and uh then we have the
science of the concept and the
philosophical encyclopedia so that that
might be
interesting I don't know the average
reader that's probably going to open up
a lot more questions than it actually
solves for them because it's designed to
like lead them into the hegelian system
but it could be a good starting point
and then you know once you've you know
started to get your head around Hagel
you've read through at least one of
these books at least once maybe gotten
half of what's going on maybe being a
little bit befuddled then you can start
turning to the the big books right and
so you know one of the options is in
fact to go to the phenomenology it's a
very important early work
um much more important in the 20th
century and the 21st century than it was
in the 19th century in the 19th century
it was more the later works there are
two Logics that Hagel brought out one is
called the science of logic which you
heard me reference already talking about
that with uh you know my student who who
uh we were looking at a certain section
called existence
that is a very dense work uh well worth
reading
um it'll take you a long time to work
your way through if you think that the
phenomenology is tricky I think you'll
find the science of logic even more so
then there's the Encyclopedia of the
philosophical Sciences also called the
encyclopedia logic that's a bit more I
would say easy to wrap your head around
if you've read the phenomenology and
then you read the Encyclopedia of the
philosophical Sciences you're going to
notice some overlap and actually the
same goes for reading these other works
Hegel will retrace the same ground at
multiple points and then there is of
course the fourth big book the
philosophy of right which is let's call
it social political Theory and it's a
more mature work that is that was
massively influential in the 19th
century continue to have important
influence in the 20th century where
quite a few people also used it to blame
Hegel for all sorts of things
that probably Hegel would not have been
for like say Nazism or totalitarianism
in general but these are these are works
that you can check out and I would say
make sure if you're going to study these
that you allot yourself plenty of time
to do so Hegel is not somebody who
you're going to blaze your way through
let alone speed read or anything like
that you gotta you gotta work uh quite a
bit with this so maybe you know uh this
year you study the phenomenology after
reading some of these other texts and
then the next year after you've gone
through the phenomenology maybe once or
twice you go on to say the philosophy of
right
we should also talk about some of the
other things that Hagel wrote you've
already heard me mention some of his
lectures
uh this is one that I particularly like
the lectures on the philosophy of
religion Hegel is a lot of interesting
things to say about religion some of
which are you know possibly correct some
of which are you know a bit off base but
are still quite interesting he's got a
very complex way of understanding what
religion is about he's carrying out a
kind of philosophical anthropology these
are you know notes from what it was that
Hegel was presenting to his own students
there are also lectures on Aesthetics
which deal with the various forms of art
very interesting stuff as well we've
already mentioned the lectures on the
philosophy of History the lectures on
the history of philosophy and then
there's also lectures on you know proofs
for the existence of God and all of
these are things that you might find
worth digging into and you could
approach some of those before going to
the phenomenology if you're really
interested in what Hagel has to say
about religion I would actually suggest
going to these lectures you know and
seeing what you've got uh there rather
than looking at the much shorter and
um you know in some respects more
summary treatments of religion for
example in the phenomenology if you want
to know what Hegel thinks about
particular philosophers read the
lectures on the philosophy of History
rather than just focusing on the
phenomenology seeing where they fit in
with that or the philosophy of right or
the various Logics right and now we
should also talk about
um secondary literature
it's you know incredibly tempting to
think that oh this is so hard maybe I
shouldn't start by actually reading
Hegel maybe I should read some stuff
about Hegel and you know I think that
that could be a decent way to go and you
want to keep in mind with any secondary
literature that you're getting an
interpretation of Hegel you're not
approaching Hegel directly and the
interpretations can be very uh well
thought out well argued you know rather
faithful to hegel's own spirit and text
but they are still interpretations so
you do need to be a bit careful about
that and I'm going to begin by talking
about histories of philosophy so
I actually it was a recent history of
Philosophy by AAC Grayling and he's got
a section on Hegel and what do we find
him doing you know giving some summary
about hegel's biography and what he's
interested in and by the time that we um
get to
uh you know a few pages in we see that
Hegel is is uh being identified with
here we go
uh a given State of Affairs can be
thought of as the thesis to which an
opposite an antithesis poses itself from
the confrontation between them emerges a
new State of Affairs is the synthesis
the synthesis becomes a new thesis to
which another antithesis opposes itself
thus producing a further synthesis this
again becomes the thesis to which an
antithesis opposes itself and so on and
so on the final self-understanding of
Geist spirit is the final synthesis of
the historical dialectical chain that
brought it to this point now
you may not know much about Hegel but at
least you should know that Hegel did not
work in terms of thesis antithesis
synthesis and you know
you could say that he does so at times
but you know take the phenomenology you
are not going to find that happening
here you will find triadic schemas you
will find developments but you are not
going to find this uh
cookie cutter approach that so many
people are crediting Hegel with and
Grayling seems to have just you know
uncritically bought into from others I'm
trying to look around from my Friedrich
hobbleston uh and it's not coming
immediately to mind but you know
Friedrich cobbleston another person who
wrote a history of philosophy a long
time ago he's got an entire section on
why you shouldn't attribute to Hegel
thesis antithesis synthesis he's a more
faithful historian of philosophy so you
want to be a little careful in who you
use for your interpreters when we're
talking about histories of philosophy
that are not just focused on Hegel and
then there's all sorts of other things
that you might turn to that would be you
know potentially helpful
um
two books that will be familiar to
anybody who's like learning about hey go
through the Continental tradition
Alexander kojev's introduction to the
reading of Hegel well worth checking out
I would say that you you're getting more
uh courgette than you are Hegel even
though he is quoting Hegel quite a lot
and trying to connect things uh you know
historically to to different movements
and ideas and developments
um and it's not going to like so long as
you don't assume that kojav is the
perfect interpreter it's not going to
destroy your capacity to understand
Hegel somebody who's a little bit more
faithful I would say Jean If Elite
Genesis and structure of hegel's
phenomenology of spirit I I like this
hippolete by the way was the French
translator of Hegel and um you know his
his translation is quite interesting
it's got lots and lots of footnotes if
you read French you might want to check
it out here's a few other things David
James Hagel a guide for the perplexed uh
you know not bad it begins an
interesting ways it starts with uh
basically with you know
um
hegel's philosophy of subjective spirit
and then jumps right into the philosophy
of right and kind of works its way
around you know it's got a section on
Art and religion uh metaphysics of
Freedom uh it's connecting Hegel up with
different people and so you're getting
another take
um I remember reading this Stanley
rosen's book years and years and years
ago gwf Hegel an introduction of the
science of wisdom uh you know Rosen is a
is a very interesting
American reader of Continental
philosophy you could say the same about
Kaufman as well you know some some
recent stuff you may recognize this
massive Tome by Robert Brandon a spirit
of trust a reading of hegel's
phenomenology brandom succeeds in
providing a reading which is even longer
than Vehicles phenomenology but it's
it's quite interesting it's well
organized there's a lot of you could
call it historical
research that goes into this connecting
the dots also you can say that hip Elite
is good with that and Brandon recently
also gave here in Milwaukee this little
uh you know book is his Aquinas lecture
heroism and magnanimy uh the postmodern
form of self-conscious agency gave this
in 2019 and I was actually there for it
it was quite quite a nice session that
he gave you know skipping back a little
bit here's some other things here's
holgate's introduction to Hegel which I
think is uh you know a decent
work to get your head around that
um he begins by saying opinions about
Hagel are to say the least mixed right
and that's that's quite true
um and I think that holgates
commentaries is quite useful
um
we've got Robert Solomon the great
existentialist writer who you know
predictably enough says the Hegel who
will emerge from the following pages and
from the phenomenal he's a very humanist
and human Hegel right a little bit
scrolling down he says
um he is an existentialist of sorts as
mariloponte argued some 25 years ago so
you know Solomon is interpreting Hegel
in his particular way and then you know
has a nice uh glossary of terms
translated into ordinary English those
sorts of things can be very useful the
other one I mean there's many many
secondary sources I'm not going to go
through all of them but one of the other
ones I I would like to mention is you
know if you don't know Martin Heidegger
actually gave lectures on Hegel and I
think these are quite insightful it's
unfortunate that the lecturers only
cover the uh very first parts of the
phenomenology of spirit and that is why
they are so short you might also look at
collections of essays here's a common
you know example Cambridge companion to
Hegel I believe this was edited by uh
yeah okay Biser
so you've got you know things on hegel's
intellectual development
um his conception of logic the
dialectical method hegel's ethics you
know and by some some really you know
great Hegel Scholars so this this sort
of thing can be quite interesting and
you'll find all sorts of guides there is
also one other book that I would like to
bring up in some respect In a
Sentimental way so this is Hegel a
collection of critical essays from 1972.
so a little bit dated
edited by Aleister McIntyre and he's
bringing together Walter Kaufman Finley
Robert Solomon who we just talked about
Charles Taylor Aleister McIntyre has a
wonderful essay in there uh called Hegel
on faces and skulls which is uh about
one particular section of the
phenomenology but also has some great
implications for other matters and I I
think this is uh quite good he also
begins no philosophers suffered more
from enthusiastic misrepresentation than
Hegel sometimes by professed followers
More Often by would-be critics and no
philosopher not even Plato or Marx has
aroused more violent passions the result
is the existence of a very odd
literature about Hegel and I think
that's that's a great way to cap this
off when you're reading secondary
literature about Hegel it can be
Illuminating it can be very helpful but
you're always getting it from somebody
bodies take sooner or later you want to
read Hegel for himself and for yourself
so that's probably enough about like
which text to begin with again I don't
suggest beginning with the phenomenology
but I know that half of you are probably
going to do that so you know forewarned
is for armed and let's move on to the
next stuff
as with any philosopher who you're going
to attempt to study on your own or even
with the help of other people
understanding them within a certain
context is important the historical
context of intellectual context and
understanding their own motivations as
far as we can tell what they are they're
projects what it is that they're about
all of that can be very helpful to keep
in mind so let's start by talking about
historical context to begin with you
know Hegel is part of this movement that
we often call German idealism and we you
know credit Kant for really getting it
rolling idealism is not something
absolutely new with Kant Kant himself
talks about Descartes and Barclay and
others as idealists and distinguishes
his own form against them and you know
Kant has this critical project going on
a lot of people think that well you'd
have to read the first critique the
critique of pure reason before you can
approach Hegel I don't actually think
that that's the case I think that you
can you know maybe learn a few things
about what Kant was doing and then jump
into the Hegel but of course you know if
you can if you know the references it is
quite useful sometimes to
have those in mind it produces a richer
reading experience and you know there's
a lot of other people coming after Kant
we talk about you know for example ficta
and shelling and then Hegel and then
we've got people like shop and Howard
and we've got these you know post
hegelians who are sort of in his shadow
and hagel's right there in the middle of
all of this and one of the things you
know so this term idealism one of the
things that is really centrally
associated with it is kind of an
optimism about the human capacity to to
understand the world to understand
ourselves understand our relations with
others including those in the past and
those uh yet to come and to frame this
in terms of something that we could you
know have in our mind and that's that's
part of what Hegel is doing you know he
thinks that the world has has indeed
changed in important respects with this
you know New Philosophy that's coming on
the scene that he takes himself as like
you know really developing further
so that's an important idea to keep in
mind that's not radically new Descartes
thinks uh he's developing a you know a
new philosophy there's others in in time
as well but with Hegel you can say that
he's part of this really important
historical movement that we typically
call the enlightenment it's also in
German the ALF claron right or The
siecta Lumiere in French and what we're
talking about is a time period really
straddling the 18th and 19th centuries
the early part of it where there's this
you know idea that we can rework uh
Humanity social structures maybe get rid
of religion maybe purify it maybe do all
sorts of other things bring philosophy
and you know the human capacity for
reason front and center get away from
arbitrary Arrangements make things more
free and Hagel will himself talk about
his own philosophy and the things that
he's studying as a sort of Developmental
history of human Freedom becoming more
and more free over time so those are all
you know important things to consider to
have in the background if you want to
read Kant beforehand yeah you can do
that you don't have to necessarily as I
said read the first critique it might
actually be more helpful if you want to
read critiques to read the second one
the critique of practical reason it
could be very helpful to read things
like religion within the limits of
reason alone or the metaphysics of
morals or the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals there's no one
single context that you have to take a
look at
and you know hegel's also drawing upon
and responding to people like ficta and
shelling and some of the other people
who are in the background as well so
that's you know one thing to to keep in
mind
um you know understanding hegel's own
project and and not just his project but
I think you could say a number of other
people's projects as well we sometimes
joke about you know uh the German
idealism and completing the system of
German idealism and that's kind of an
anachronistic joke because all of that
business was happening 200 years ago but
Hegel is a system builder he is working
at things systematically he wants to
articulate for us and think through and
invite us into this let's call it
intelligible totality that brings
everything into it you know he's he's
got a rather ambitious conception of
what philosophy itself can do when
properly transformed not Khan's
philosophy not Descartes philosophy not
Aristotle's philosophy not lockian
philosophy but something something new
something that is
up to the task of philosophical work and
system building and inquiry so that's
you know important I would say to keep
in mind philosophy is also viewed as as
sort of like the central discipline
you know as opposed to going to a
university today where you know you
might have to struggle to find the
philosophy department and there's only a
few classes that undergraduates are
taking philosophy was viewed by Hegel
and many other people of his time as
being like the most the most Central the
most important discipline that would
bring together all of the others and you
know there were alternate models but
Hagel would say well sooner or later
you're doing philosophy like it or not
so may as well do it in a really good
way
that's not a conception of philosophy
that everybody even in the the
discipline of philosophy shares at the
present but that is something that is
driving hegel's work he views philosophy
as unifying the other disciplines as
saying what's important in them in in
judging and organizing them and
observing their their development as as
well so that's important to keep in mind
um he's also as you can tell even if
you've only read a few glosses on Hegel
super super into this idea of historical
development the notion that human beings
and their Consciousness and even human
reason or this thing that we call Spirit
Geist has been developing over time in a
cumulative process that doesn't always
include success stories sometimes there
are impasses there are dead ends that
you know you have to come back out of
and go around and Hegel thinks that he
can observe and chart out and perhaps
even contribute to in a certain way this
very development that we're talking
about and he makes that something
absolutely Central to his philosophy
history is you could say
highlighted as uh absolutely important
for philosophy in a way that
arguably it wasn't prior to Hegel I mean
this is a Heidegger's claim I mean we
can talk about other people
in philosophy talking about historical
developments you know think about human
Hobbs and their views on how religion
develops or think about Jean-Jacques
Rousseau but they're not doing it quite
in the way that Hegel is doing it nor
with the
incredible emphasis that Hegel is
placing on historical development so I
think that's another thing that might be
helpful to keep in mind
um
I I think that one other thing because I
don't want to overload you with this
that might be helpful as well to realize
heading in
so we often think of philosophy as
something that we do as individuals and
you know we get to pick and choose and
judge and all that sort of stuff and
that that's true but the individual as
individual is not really that important
except for you know World historical
individuals who come along every once in
a while and that's because they're not
just themselves they're they're they're
embodying an idea or living out or
developing something that has World
historical uh implications
but what is really really important for
Hegel
are you could say let's say five main
domains I mean there is also you know
perception and the sciences and stuff
like that but let's put that aside for a
minute where does Hegel think that
spirit
develops itself most fully well there's
what we can call moral life which for
Hegel is uh zitikite we often translate
that as ethical life and we talk about
you know projects and you can see this
in the phenomenology but in other works
as well but there's also morality
morality which is a little bit uh
different opposed to it something that
comes out of the Enlightenment so we've
got this ethical domain and then we've
got the social political domain which is
also incredibly important and
encompasses law you could say as well
and these you know connect up together
and then we have the whole domain of Art
and artistic expression which includes
not just you know the plastic Arts but
also like tragedy and you know poetry
and and things along those lines that's
also very important for Hegel it assumes
you might say a greater importance as
time goes on religion massively
important for Hegel Hegel thinks that
you know religions develop within
particular cultures they're responding
to issues that that arise for us human
beings in our relationship to the gods
the absolute the Eternal trying to
figure out where we fit into the cosmos
and what we ought to do practically
but religion is to be ultimately you
could say supplanted
by philosophy and philosophy as I
mentioned is this unifying discipline so
philosophy can tell us what art really
is about or what is really going on in
political life or what's really going on
in all these interesting developments in
Morality and ethics or what's going on
in the development of religions
including the consummate religion
Christianity for Hegel you know all of
this is uh going to be discussed and
tied into
his his system which you know it's never
complete you could say uh there was at
least sort of the promise that the books
that he'd bring out would would you know
complete the system of German idealism I
don't think he actually did that but he
he certainly goes a long way and so
keeping these things in mind about
hegel's context and about his own
motivations as he tells us about them
may be helpful for you as you carry out
your studies
there is some useful advice that I can
give you as somebody who's been studying
Hegel boy for you know more than half my
life and teaching about Hegel that is
derived from the let's call it the
format of uh hegel's works and his
writing and his modes of thinking so the
first thing I want to say is is a
caution what you should avoid doing
because I've seen it trip up so many
people and that is to approach hegel's
philosophy as if you can begin with a
bunch of definitions and then proceed
deductively and understand things or or
at least catch Hegel in a lie or
something like that it's not that kind
of philosophy you're you're if you do
that approach you are deliberately
setting yourself up to not understand
what hegel's doing so you know key
hegeli in terms you do want to try to
you know find out out what what people
think that they mean and see you know
where they come up you know for example
the distinction between being in itself
you know on zeaxine sometimes also
translated as implicit being and being
for itself enthusiac sign along with uh
you know being for others you know being
in and for itself and all that sort of
stuff you can you can find out
um what people think about those but the
real meaning of these is not always
exactly the same in every instance that
hegel's using them so you don't want to
mistakenly assume that this always means
this you know some philosophers they're
aiming at that sort of University you
could say of language and Concepts Hegel
is definitely doing something different
than that
I would also say right off the bat
another negative thing
avoid relying upon quotes or quips or
sound bites you know there's all sorts
of things out there that people have
quoted from Hegel including the silly uh
you know on his deathbed Eagles saying
that only one man has understood me and
even him he didn't understand me
put that sort of sort of nonsense out of
your head some of these things may sound
cool but they're not going to help you
understand hegel's writings and his
thought including these quips like
spirit is a bone well it is a bone in a
couple paragraphs of the phenomenology
but then that's to say it's not and
there's much more going on so don't
screw yourself over by finding some
passages and thinking oh this explains
everything you got to go to the texts
right another thing that I think you
should probably do
suspend I'm not saying reject altogether
but at least like suspend or bracket or
put put aside nullify preconceptions
that you're approaching hegel's texts
with you know for example I've mentioned
the thesis antithesis synthesis thing
it's not as if it's completely wrong
um but it's not going to be productive
for you to bring that in from some
secondary text or from a website and say
aha I know exactly what hagel's doing
because what you're doing then is you're
taking this incredibly complex thought
and you're as we say shoehorning it into
these boxes that are convenient for you
but are going to result in you not
understanding what you're reading and
you know there's a lot of other
preconceptions that somebody might bring
to hagel's text I would suggest you know
putting those aside and what does this
have to do with the format of hagel's
Works Hegel himself thinks that
philosophy needs to as much as it can be
you know
presuppositionlessness it's gotta go at
the material and and look at it you know
straight on and then make sense of it
without imposing a whole bunch of
structure on it to begin with
another thing that I think would be
helpful for you
Hegel is developing a complex context
with each of the dialectical
developments that he is setting out for
you so you know just to take one example
um you know the most probably the most
famous section of the phenomenology is
the Master Slave dialectic and you could
put that into a couple bullet points but
you'd be wrong to do so because it's a
dialectical development right so you
need to like keep all of this in your
head at the same time this is what
conceptual or notional
thinking is actually doing as opposed to
merely you know picture thinking or
representational thinking what Hegel
calls for Stallone you know the
philosophy of the understanding as he
denigrates it for example in the uh
lectures on the philosophy of religion
um you want to approach these things as
if they are going to be
complicated and are going to be
demanding on you uh you know we'll talk
about to what degree you can you can
easily do that in just a bit but I think
that you do want to approach his texts
understanding that dialectical processes
spread out over a number of paragraphs
are not going to be neatly summed up in
a few lines or you know takeaways or
something like that you want to attend
to what's actually going on and I would
say you know you really do want to stick
with the dialectic you want to follow
along it's okay to like raise problems
and say oh I I you know I don't think
that he's going the right way with this
or why did he go this way instead of
this way why did he switch to this topic
instead of this that's all fair game
but if you do want to understand Hegel
you do have to kind of go along with him
at least you know where you are in the
The Works and the last thing I'll say
about this is you know Hegel thinks that
philosophy involves you could you could
call it cumulative processes where we're
putting things together into larger and
larger holes complicated structures that
we can wrap our heads around and realize
that we ourselves have a place in this
very wrapping our heads around right
that's part of what it means to be
conceptual right or to engage in
sublation or auf habong another key term
for Hegel as well so if you do that and
you let yourself you could say
uh
read into the texts and take them as if
they're an interesting story or an
interesting
discussion by somebody who may be wrong
on some points but actually has a lot to
contribute you will probably get a lot
more out of the reading as you're going
along with it and hegel's texts are
really set up in that sort of way the
last thing that I'll say I mentioned
this term alphabel right
which we often translate as sublation
there's other ways of rendering it
and I said this is very important and it
is very important so when you go from
one section to another to another in
hegel's text you should realize that the
earlier sections what's important in
them ideally is being brought along
and Incorporated in what's essential to
it into the next structures and you will
see in some of hegel's texts you know
where he's referring back he's like hey
this what was going what's going on here
is similar to what was happening back in
this part but it's also different so you
know pay attention to those those
connections and
um you know don't move from one section
to the next as if you can get through it
and you know think it through and then
now you leave it behind all together and
and you know I said that was the last
thing but I will say one other thing as
well
you can't speed run through Hegel you
can't uh read the stuff as quickly as
possible
this is not the sort of writing or text
most philosophy doesn't reward that
anyway it's foolish to do that but
there's a lot of people out there who
seem to think that you can like you know
run your eyes over the text as quickly
as possible and take it into your brain
that's the opposite of the approach that
Hegel would advise for you and I think
if he were here in the present he'd be
like you know approaching people who are
doing that smacking them in the back of
the head and saying knock it off dummy
uh don't don't do that let's let's do a
different sort of approach so these are
things that are are you know maybe
helpful for you to keep in mind derived
from the format the style of hegel's own
texts
with Hegel more than perhaps most other
thinkers that I've come across there's a
lot of you could say problems and issues
that the beginner the person of first
approaching Hegel
might be tempted to get worried about or
even obsessed over that I think our you
know they're not uh
totally off base and to be put aside
forever but they're not going to be
helpful for you at the beginning and I
think that they wind up leading a lot of
people to
spin their wheels so to speak rather
than get traction and move ahead so you
know the first one that I would say is
you know if you're approaching Hegel
because you're in some sort of you know
community of friends or fellow readers
and they're all about being on let's
call it team Hegel you know Hagel is
always right and you know we just have
to figure out what this brilliant man
has said I would put that aside I
wouldn't worry about like trying to make
sure that everything comes out perfect
as you're studying Hegel because Hegel
you know he makes some mistakes like
everybody does there's there's things
that he didn't talk about there's
matters that he did talk about and it
looks like he got him wrong and that's
okay you don't have to feel an
obligation to somehow in your mind
defend Hegel to yourself you can just
read the stuff and you're going to be so
much better off if you do that now
there's a flip side there are so many
critics of Hegel out there and you know
some of them actually have some some
decent things to say some of them have
decent things to say but but draw the
wrong conclusions from those criticisms
that they have some of the criticisms uh
show that the person really didn't
understand Hegel or might be reacting
less against Hegel and more against
hegelians you know a lot of kierkegaards
criticisms I would say Syrian kicker
guards are more directed at the
hegelians of his time than at Hegel
himself and then you know there's some
that are unfair and here's the thing you
don't actually have to defend Hegel
against all these other people either if
Carl popper wants to think that you know
Hegel was you know leading us towards
totalitarianism and against you know
opens societies and led to Fascism hey
Carl popper can be wrong and
mean-spirited and and foolish in that
respect as much as he wants it doesn't
have to do anything with you right and
the guy's long dead you don't have to
worry about that if Bertrand Russell or
you know I mentioned A.G Grayling want
to get Hegel wrong that's not affecting
you you don't have to worry about that
as you're reading hegel's text every
single philosopher is criticized by not
just somebody but a whole bunch of
somebody's you know pick anyone that you
want if they've got you know any sort of
let's call it notoriety or fame
somebody's going after them so you don't
have to worry about that yourself I will
also say
you know once again shifting back to
this this topic of criticism Hegel
himself is engaging in criticism of a
number of different movements and ideas
and approaches to things sometimes he's
on base sometimes he's off or he's only
getting partly uh things right so again
you don't have to worry so much about
that as you're studying it so for
example in the phenomenology
hegel's discussion of stoicism there is
clearly not engaged with historical
stoicism it's engaged with something of
a caricature which was becoming kind of
common in his time there's a story that
we could tell about that but it's
clearly an inadequate picture of the
philosophical system movement whatever
you want to call it of stoicism his
discussions of it it in the history of
philosophy a little bit better still not
entirely there
what you want to do is figure out well
what what is what's right in his
criticism what what is he actually
targeting what does he have in mind what
can I get from this his discussion and
the phenomenology of the phrenology and
um you know physiognomy of his time holy
crap is that good that has massive
implications not just for those two
disciplines at that time but even for
the
over inflated claims made by some people
today on the basis of you know what's
going on with brain States or pick
whatever else you want that has to do
with the relationship between
Consciousness and and the body so you
know some of his critiques are really on
point some of them aren't don't worry at
this point about whether the critiques
are entirely correct or something like
that just see what he's actually saying
and then you can work at it later on
after you've you know looked at those
those matters that he's uh looking at
rather negatively
another thing I've already mentioned
Hegel did not get everything right you
don't need to be preoccupied as you're
reading it through with determining you
know here's the stuff you got right
here's the stuff he got wrong and
drawing a nice list that's got you know
everything set up on different sides
that's part of the process of you
studying it first you got to actually
understand what the guy is saying and
that's difficult right so figure out
what he's saying before worrying about
whether he's 100 correct about stuff and
if he's not 100 correct that doesn't
mean that the philosophy is valueless or
even that studying the stuff that he
seems to get wrong is without value you
can get a lot out of figuring out well
where does he actually go wrong but
first you have to understand the stuff
another thing that I've seen people
sometimes get caught uh snagged let's
say in the process of studying Hegel is
they'll try to understand a paragraph in
a difficult section like force in the
understanding and they can't figure out
what hagel's saying and they're like I'm
stuck on this paragraph I can't move on
to the other stuff
no move on to the other stuff you'll
come back to that paragraph and maybe it
will make more sense the next time
around you don't have to you know
understand every single thing as you're
going along or else it's totally you
know without value you're you've lost
the path of the dialectic no that's not
the way it works it's not the way it
works with most other philosophers if
you're reading Descartes and you don't
understand something and you've you know
made some good efforts to try to figure
out what the hell he's saying or Kant or
whoever else
it's okay to move on to the next thing
it's not going to damage your brain as a
matter of fact you're more likely to
screw yourself up by obsessing at this
one point I have to figure out what this
is right you just move on and you can
figure it out later on you can come back
to it later on
um and the other thing that I'll say too
is you know where Hegel is wrong and
sometimes we could say deplorably so you
know the criticisms that we can make of
him for you know racism or ethnocentrism
you know for example when he says in the
philosophy of history that Africa has no
history and you're like well that
doesn't sound right uh clearly it does
you know these are the sort of things
where you you set it aside you don't
need to be worried about that right now
somebody can be you know racist and also
um be you know a philosopher who's got
some things to contribute in other
matters right so you don't believe Hegel
when it comes to Africa and history or
you know the hierarchy of different
types of people you can say Ah that's
that's a product of the
um backwards racist ideas of of the time
and you know some prejudices and you
know pre-judging things
um same thing with his uh you could
accuse him of gender essentialism or
misogyny or being patriarchal
yeah he is I mean that is uh how he he
thought of things in terms of men and
women and the family and uh that that
whole stuff that doesn't have to mean
that you can't get anything out of uh
studying his work maybe you come back to
it later on and you can produce
criticisms and say here's what we need
to keep and here's what we need to get
rid of that's fine but the first time
you're going through a hegelian tax it's
probably not going to be helpful for you
to approach it with all of that as your
your main thing that you're trying to do
the key thing is to develop
understanding
and I'll say to you what I say to my
students in nearly every class where
we're reading original texts every
semester
there's appreciation right and if you
appreciate Hegel that's great there's
agreements there is endorsement
and then there's understanding and you
you really can't do these other things
in any competent way
without understanding understanding
comes first you don't have to agree with
somebody to understand them you don't
have to appreciate them to understand
them you don't have to endorse them to
understand them but you do need to
understand them if you want to
competently
you know in a well-grounded way do any
of these other things so all of this
hopefully gives you
some pointers for how you can do
precisely that it's not going to be easy
Hegel is one of the more difficult
thinkers that you can encounter but
hopefully some of this advice will be
helpful for you as you engage in
self-directed study I do have a few
resources you know for derived from the
half hour Hegel project if you're going
into the phenomenology that could be
helpful for you a lot of commentary
videos I'm getting close to having
finished the entire series but there's a
lot of other great stuff out there that
you can access as well including
lectures on the science of logic and you
just have to look around and you'll
you'll find these people and sites and
channels where these resources are
available for you I think that it is
definitely worth studying Hegel I hope
that you will all at least some of you
viewers will take on the task or if
you're already doing it continue the
task of trying to make sense out of this
very important 19th century German
idealist thinker